どうもそう日本の海は初めてだっけもう
一度お願いしますが a
東モスは日本の海に行ったことあるあの
いいえまだですそしてアワーすかっ州の海
はとても寒いので今日は楽しみですそっか
相当寒いんだろうねさぁみんな車持って8
棟マンスは助手席にいなジョジョ集積ここ
に座るそれともここに座るあ私はここに
座りますありがとうございますじゃあと
思うこと亮太後ろはーいうんわかった車の
中チョても暑いですねそうだねほんとで
冷房をつけるからちょっと待って
よし罰原因里さんとても暑いです ac お
願いします ac で何かなエアコンの事
を言ってると思うよっぱやこねえトーマス
今車乗ったばっかりだからまだつけれない
んだその代わりにまだ理由とかからねすみ
ません窓じゃありません a carお
願いしますすっごく暑いです1とトーマス
はナス科出身だから車の冷房のことを知ら
ないんじゃない私はエアコンをつけます
消えないそうかた先に熱風が出るのを知ら
ないんだろうねと唐茄子これまだ暑いです
そうホットッだからちょっと待ってね
ホットちゃありません言え青いほうつかい
ますやそうだけど出発したばっかりだから
今をつけたら逆にネップが出るんだネップ
は何ですかおとうさん大丈夫大丈夫
どう熱い風のことだだからちょっとだけ
待ってくれると木を詰めたよちゃかなんか
ないわよいいえ私は待つことができません
さあ一越中肺炎フィギュア悲愴アンディ
スキャナーや
すぐ付からちょっとだけ待ってね私はこれ
はこれを私はどうもちゃんと止めてね
あんた私はこれを使いますフォーム待っ
てって今つけたら逆に大変なことになる
からどーやんべる名計4お父さん強い
トーン町田刺し寒いのあんたみんなに息
止めて愛情部でse
me